Negative 7 5ths and 2 are the correct answers. Amazing work. You got this one
correct. When we start solving this problem, we want them multiplied by the LCD
which is x times x plus 1. It's the product of these two denominators. We cancel
the factors that reduce to 1 and then we distribute the remaining factors here
on x terms. So we'll have 5x times x plus 1 Plus 6 times x, which equals 14
times x plus 1. Next, we distribute the 5x and the 14 to get our new equation. I
have a quadratic term here, so I know I need to factor. I'm going to move these
terms to the left side, so that way I can set this equation, or this left hand
side of my equation, equal to 0. We'll combine like terms first by adding 5x and
6x. To get 11x. Next we'll subtract these two terms from both sides of our
equation. The 14 doesn't have a like term on this side of the equation, so I put
it last. This gives us five x squared minus three x minus 14 which equals zero.
Next we want to factor this quadratic by find the factors of negative 70 That
sum to negative 3. These factors are negative 10 and positive 7. We use these 2
factors to rewrite our middle term, and factor by grouping. So this quadratic
can be factored as 5x plus 7 times x minus 2. We want to make sure that we set
it equal to zero. So we can set each factor equal to zero. And solve for x. We
set this first factor equal to 0. And the second factor equal to 0. Doing so we
can solve and get x equal to negative 7 5ths, and x is equal to positive 2. But
we're not done yet. We want to make sure we check the excluded values to see if
either of these are not part of the solution. Well, the only excluded values are
x equals 0 and x equals negative 1. If x were 0 this fraction would be
undefined. And if x is equal to negative one, this fraction would be undefined.
So our two values of negative 7 fifths and positive 2 are correct.